Welcome back to the David Pakman show.
OK.
Let's get right back to the phones at six
one seven eight three zero forty seven fifty.
There are many people who are hoping to get
on the phone.
Let's go to our caller from the two one five
area code.
Who's calling from two one five.
Today.
I made a mistake.
Yeah.
Who's this?
This is Ryan.
I'm actually calling from Raleigh, North Carolina.
All right.
And we're not on speaker phone, are we?
No.
Do you need I you are my headset and I need
you to get out.
I think it's okay.
Never.
I just had a quick question about Biden's
environmental plan.
So, as we know, he's using the Green UDR framework,
as you said.
And one of the things to my understanding
that he's using is easy, easy, including nuclear
power.
The issue is environmental plan.
I was kind of hoping to get your idea or I
guess your thoughts on nuclear power in general.
And then I think the American people think
about it.
So I like this question because I think that
there is a lot of mis misinformation and mistaken
beliefs about nuclear among some on the left
who are just reflexively against it.
And often the reason that people on the left
are against nuclear power is because they
imagine that new nuclear with modern technology
would have all of the same risks that existed
40 and 50 years ago with nuclear, which is
simply not true.
So I actually, in principle, don't have a
problem with nuclear.
New nuclear as a bridge to getting to alternative
energy at some hopefully defined point in
the future.
I think that people on the left who just say
it's unsafe don't understand how dramatically
different modern nuclear would be and the
ways the technologies that would make, you
know, a so-called meltdown almost impossible.
So that's one piece of it.
The problem I have with nuclear is that it
takes a long time to get new nuclear capacity
online.
And I question whether the time it would take
to do it would simply be a disincentive and
would just justify delaying getting on clean
renewables altogether.
And so that's my question mark.
I don't remember how many years it is that
it takes to put new nuclear online, but I
would like to be significantly in the direction
of clean renewables by then.
And I wouldn't want the project of doing new
nuclear to delay what what eventually should
be the the end goal.
But I think the people who are just like,
oh, it's just unsafe.
We can we shouldn't do it.
I'm open to the idea of nuclear as a bridge.
But I would want to be really clear about
how do we get back off of it.
Yeah.
No, I totally agree with that.
I'm actually going for my doctorate in nuclear
engineering.
I'm kind of biased or a Darwell guy.
Well, I don't have to tell you that.
You know that.
Yeah, no.
Good.
I just want to get your take on it and see
your take on how the American people would
kind of feel about it.
I'm definitely on board for dispose of our
Lesterville system works and how everything's
on demand and, you know, wind and solar and
nice and stuff.
But we don't have the capabilities to store
that energy RVL economically.
So, you know, nuclear is definitely one of
the options to get on demand power that's
definitely carbon free.
Yeah, I think you'll have.
I think we will have the ability as the energy
storage problem, I believe is going to be
solved.
But you're right that right now it is a it
is a problem that we have not yet solved.
Thanks so much for your typically memorable
day.
All right.
Thank you.
Appreciate the phone call